tu ragazzi Ben ritrovati E siamo di
nuovo a Tokyo perché ho cambiato albergo
Come avete visto alla fine dell'altro
video in questo video andremo a seoul ma
i primi due giorni li passerò a Tokyo
poi gli chiederete Ma che cazzo si
chiama ragazzi se rule and Tower ed è a
shibuya ed è uno degli alberghi più
carini qua mi hanno lasciato
sta uscendo qualcuno voliamoci che sono
sociale Questo è il giornale è una cosa
molto simpatica questa perché io non so
leggere dove cazzo sta il tasto del Bari
sarà una luce di merda non c'è la luce
del bagno se riuscissi a trovare il
tasto del bar però non a quest'ora
cominciamo dal bagno umile umile c'è
anche il coso per sedersi perché uno non
c'ha voglia di Lavarsi i denti in piedi
ma è anche molto scomodo se ci fate caso
perché non so se si vede ma tipo il
lavandino mi arriva sotto il Pipi Quindi
è anche difficile io ci posso pisciare
nel lavandino dopodiché abbiamo un cesso
tipico giapponese molto molto carino
Ovviamente la doccia è compresa di vasca
ed è grossa come un monolocale da 700
euro a Milano e dopodiché possiamo
passare alla camera vera e propria
colonna Pepsi che ieri ho rubato e
voilà ho dormito su due letti non sto
scherzando a un certo punto ho cambiato
letto perché farà caldo mi sono fatto
anche portare la cena ieri sera perché
già che c'ero ho detto vabbè servizi in
camera dobbiamo fare 30 facciamo 31
dobbiamo fare surry facciamolo Power
abbiamo due poltrone che unite possono
fare il divano e il pezzo migliore
ragazzi della serum Tower la vista
perché si vede tutta Tokyo questo
momento mi trovo al ventottesimo che non
è il piano più alto Eh ce ne sono tipo
40 e uno degli hotel più alti perché da
qua praticamente c'è una vista simile a
quella che potresti avere alla Tokyo
Tower siamo più bassi della Tokyo driver
per l'amor di Dio però essendo uno dei
palazzi più alti si vede comunque tutto
questa è la parte est di Tokyo Se non
erro Nonostante sia la parte comunque
meno meno bella tra virgolette niente
male perché se notate laggiù si vede il
Monte Fuji ora c'è un pochettino di
nebbia quindi si vede poco comunque uno
si siede davanti a sta finestra magica e
loro ti portano il giornale il
telecomando sembra quello per attivare
un Transformer perché c'è tutta questa
parte di comandi aggiuntivi che anche se
hanno tentato di spiegarmeli Comunque
non si capisce una sera Adesso accendo
vedo che cosa c'è in tv in Giappone come
ultima cosa Questo è il wi-fi
dell'albergo lan Tower e il nome della
rete e la password è Tokyo Hotel
va bene Oh Vediamo che succede Ecco qua
c'è proprio voglia lui di stare là si
vede Ciao mi hanno obbligato a fare
questa cosa ti prego Cambia canale e lo
accontentiamo Che cazzo è ragazzi che
lo si spegne usciamo perché se sto qua
mi rincoglionisco in tutto questo
Ragazzi vediamo se riusciamo ad andare a
fare colazione perché non ho provato a
vedere come il ristorante dell'albergo
con cui era il ventottesimo piano vedete
ce ne sono 40 non ce n'è neanche uno che
è dolce come cuoco o caramello
la smetto Madonna è talmente in alto e
mi si tappano le orecchie giuro non c'è
nessuno Dove si fa colazione qua bachet
information Saloon Ragazzi ma dove cazzo
sono finiti Cioè ha fatto sto posto non
posso gigantesco completamente vuoto Mi
sa che ho sbagliato piano la cosa che è
sempre divertente quando viaggio è che
io non prendo mai la colazione in
albergo a parte che costa la Madonna
vado in genere o la Starbucks
soprattutto in Giappone lo dà tali
scoffe Come avete visto negli altri vlog
però qua c'ho la colazione in un albergo
così la sfruttiamo direi Anzi chiedo
alla reception ed è breakfast Restaurant
stavo per dire Ah è proprio lui è dolce
come vuoi o caramello
è carino ragazzi perché c'è ho il buffet
oppure ordini ho ordinato tipo un
omelette e il caffè nero Bellissimo
comunque Ragazzi è molto carino c'è
anche un fiorellino anche Adesso
proviamo
Fatemi insegnare da un italiano come
fare colazione in Giappone mangiando
americano che non ha non ha senso con
del ketchup non ne capisco l'utilità
giusto perché illegale in 200 stati No
ma Ragazzi ma l'autobus brandizzato di
Player non batte il Ground hanno messo
proprio la faccia del tipo sulla porta
no pazzesco ragazzi oggi pranzettino
tattico giusto perché in questi due
giorni prima di andare in Corea non
avevo una mazza da fare a Tokyo siamo
allo jodoshi camera al negozio di
elettronica gigantesco da chiabara Non
avevo idea che ci fosse un ristorante
dal piano di sopra perché tutto quello
che c'è dopo le poltrone massaggianti
non ho mai visto fanno questi piatti
magici Meravigliosi Me l'ha detto il Bon
Tommaso che sta qua si sta sporcando
perché si è sporcato Vabbè Ah proprio
dentro oltretutto tutto sbagliato usanze
giapponesi Comunque sai questo fase soba
Questa è una specialità di Taiwan vero
vuol dire come ti ho detto prima vuol
dire girare Quindi prima era tutto sopra
quindi se ora giri tutto quello c'era un
nuovo qua prima adesso non esiste più si
mischia diventa più buono fighissimo
quindi Ragazzi ci vediamo eh Sto per
andare a Seul mi sono vestito così
perché mi sembra il modo giusto di
entrare in Corea cioè sembravo parte di
una band che hip hop mi hanno detto che
ci vogliono due ore oggi per arrivare
all'aeroporto perché ci sono dei lavori
sull'autostrada rischio perdere l'aereo
magari smetto di registrare Ok ragazzi
alla fine ho fatto in tempo ci ha messo
veramente un'ora per arrivare il taxi e
questa Se vi ricordate è la stessa
stazione dove mi sono messo l'ultima
volta ed è ufficialmente la mia zona di
comfort qua da Neda Ricordatevi se è
arrivata all'aeroporto di daneda appena
entrate Tutto a sinistra in fondo è un
corridoio ci sono queste sedie sdraio
super comode e da stamattina che ho la
nausea ogni tanto mi prende quando tipo
Sto al telefono in macchina infatti sono
stato stupido Sono dovuto andare a
prendere delle medicine mi han dato
questo che dovrebbe essere per la NASA e
Adesso la provo se non muoio continuiamo
coi video è l'unboxing più stupido che
vi abbia mai fatto nella mia vita poi
non si capisce niente potrebbe essere
qualsiasi cosa potrebbe essere la
pillola anticoncezionale
[Musica]
pillola blu o pillola rossa con questa
vedo la tana del Bianconiglio pillola
blu ragazzi
Ma la Devo ingoiare Così non devo a
sfiga'
l'ho ingoiato poi magari muoio
strano perché non sento più
[Musica]
altro non sono fan generale della Corea
come lo sono del Giappone Quindi boh è
tutta una sorpresa non so niente della
Corea niente completamente il che è
anche più eccitante perché è tutto da
scoprire e scopriamolo tardon se dirò
cazzate quando sono in giro di qua Cos'è
questa cosa incredibile magari è il
monumento number one non lo so E poi da
quando ho preso la pillola so calcolare
perfettamente la velocità di quota e il
tempo d'arrivo sempre che il pilota non
Levi prima gli ipersostentatori
dell'aereo tutte cose che ho imparato da
quando ho preso la pillola molto figo
molto figo
[Musica]
Oh Siamo arrivati all'aeroporto ragazzi
blocco già da qua perché già da qua
sembra un paradiso terrestre cioè una
roba Boh non ho mai visto nella mia vita
la sezione recupero bagagli fatta così
Bene ed eccoci qua raga subito fuori
appena metterò il piede sarà la mia
prima volta in Corea
yeah coreano
per cinque giorni ho beccato un tempo di
merda avremmo Spero tempo per rifarci
Non lo so In sti giorni non ho guardato
il meteo prendiamo subito il taxi raga
Tra l'altro mi va di culo perché non c'è
fila
[Musica]
vero Allora mi hanno lasciato
letteralmente in un sottopassaggio
accessori albergo e qua va bene non so
spiegare a questa la devo tirare 2023 va
bene
Ci hai messo quella automatica e falle
tutte no Eccoci qua ragazzi il mio test
si chiama moxy e c'è il moxy bar Madonna
che figo eh Questo è un albergo e
quest'altro è il mio che sembra quella
luci rosse perfetto anzi luci Rosa ma va
bene la reception dello stampo forse ho
sbagliato dove cazzo è la particolarità
c'è un pupazzone Ma ci sono i cabinati
ma Raga ma che posto Incredibile Questo
è atterrato nel paese dei balocchi
Meno male perché il primo viaggio dove
sono dall'altra parte del mondo dove non
sono stanco perché effettivamente solo a
due ore da Tokyo quindi sono fresco come
una rosa ehm
corridoi di sping Game va bene ed Eccoci
arrivati la nostra magica stanza vediamo
prima stanza in Corea ragazzi Bello
onesto vediamo
bello bello bello Oddio non ci credo c'è
il cesso anche qui che ti spruzza
l'acqua nel culo avevo sentito una cosa
terribile che in Corea non solo non
c'era il coso Io ho visto un video
l'amico che ti devi pulire il deretano e
la carta igienica la devi buttare nel
cestino una roba terrificante Meno male
che non è così poi Ragazzi abbiamo la
stanza bella carina onesta discreto
vediamo se c'è la vista c'è uno
stranissimo balcone che non è un balcone
Però vabbè cos'è sta cosa Che cazzo è
sta roba raga Alexa Ah sì matti cos'è
ma che controlli la stanza da Alexa ma
sto male televisore
[Musica]
c'è anche questa cosa che non ho capito
che cos'è È tipo il frigo è il frigo
Raga ma come fai a essere il frigo
attaccato al muro
ma in italiano è scritto ma come perché
questa cosa non ha senso bellissimo C'è
anche questa magica torcia che si stacca
proprio dal muro e subito Slender man
spero che non mi serva perché gli horror
in Corea Ne sapete qualcosa anche voi Eh
ragazzi allora vi faccio vedere questa
cosa perché è interessante ogni tot e mi
è già successo due volte ti arriva un
messaggio di quelli che dovrebbero
arrivarci se c'è tipo una catastrofe
nucleare e me ne sono già arrivati due
siamo in Corea quindi mi immaginate
quanto mi sto cagando addosso però non
si capisce una sega magari sto per
morire Non lo so Tu me ne sono arrivati
E a proposito di outfit la
prima cosa che voglio fare ora che
uscirò a Seul per la mia prima volta
utilizzare appunto l'abbigliamento
adeguato Eccoci qua
e vado subito a ripagare i miei debiti
e quindi ragazzi a parte lo schermo che
è completamente impazzito ma credo sia
colpa del telefono più che altro
vedo che loro comunque se si vantano e
cioè coreana hotel e questo è uno di
main parchi che ci sono è un incrocio
tra Tokyo e New York tutto tenuto molto
bene e ci sono un sacco di mascotte in
giro senza un fottutissimo motivo Io non
ho la minima idea di che cosa sia sto
posto però appena entri c'è questo ma
scalinata umile va bene mmm Perché mi
avete consigliato questo posto c'è un
giga schermo dov'è La signora può fare
le foto figo Salve signora Ah ma perché
c'è un piano dedicato al k-pop Ecco
perché daivin to the k-pop in Corea No
vabbè lasciamo un Musa dedicata anche
hip hop
cos'è stato incredibile questi sono
tutti artisti k-pop fate in miniatura
quest'anno riprendendo qua Ah ah ah
lei ne sa ne sa
[Musica]
va bene andiamo avanti No ma Ragazzi ma
che posto incredibile ma cos'è Ma cos'è
pazzesco
Oh my god Comunque ragazzi mi sto
vergognando ve lo giuro perché secondo
me la gente che mi vede con questo Pensa
che io voglia non lo so dire Ehi sono
vestito come quegli iscritti game invece
non c'entra una sega Questa è la mia
felpa però sembra Quindi secondo me la
gente si triggera quando passo in giro
quindi quando riesco me la sbottono e
cerco di far finta di niente È bello sto
posto comunque Ah qua c'è una navicella
spaziale va bene Raga ma che cazzo cos'è
Alien isolation cos'è non mi spuntarli
dal condotto fighissimo l'impressione
che mi da questa città ragazzi è che sia
una città Social e tutto fatto per fare
i selfie loro predispongono le cose in
modo tale che tu possa condividere tutto
quello che fai è No però poi ci sta in
realtà secondo piano è cinema credo
Penso siano tutti i film coreani Ah vedi
C'è anche El Bond ah vediamo se c'è
Eccolo è perfetto Comunque non mi è
incredibile ragazzi cioè è pazzesca sta
roba cioè è incredibile e io non mi sono
vestito così apposta Questa è la mia
felpa Infatti ho paura di andare in giro
così Però vabbè finché nessuno mi
schiaffeggia in metro tutto ok e qua
invece c'è un murales con tutti i poster
delle serie TV Netflix coreane che sono
andate bene e qua ti fa capire quanto
stanno catturando altro che Milano Eh
2020 una faccina davanti proprio se ne
stanno cantando un sacco di sta roba e
fanno anche bene perché sono venute
benissimo le serie bravissimi ma la mia
opera preferita coreana è parasate
insieme in realtà non è la mia preferita
insieme a snowpiercer che entrambi sono
dello stesso regista quello infatti
volevo vedere se c'è il post Ecco in
realtà questa mi mancava Eh il senso non
trovo sono piercer vabbè sti cazzi al
piano successivo Ragazzi abbiamo la
caverna il nome del posto Non so come si
pronunci Scusate incontrati in
Madre Natura Eh vabbè vediamo in che
senso ci stanno le cose bisogna fare
silenzio con Sara una sala cinema mi
siedo qua mi siedo qua sento un
vecchietto che guarda sulle panchine e
poi diciamo schermo gigante non ho
capito il senso di questa cosa è figo
però questo l'ho capito
ma mi sono rotto le palle ragazzi
direi di andare là Però ragazzi non mi
sono informato da buoni youtuber su cosa
sto andando a fare quindi chi se ne
frega andiamo in giro a caso ed eccoce
l'entrata di Porta Venezia la signora
che mi aspettava vabbè Tutto chiaro Meno
male che l'hanno scritto io ho il
biglietto che ho preso a 1000 Won che
sarebbe tipo meno di €1 vediamo se
riesco a applicare Eh signori Io volevo
fa' qua Vabbè Ah ah
ah
ok Ammazza oh Grazie signore fichissimo
bene dove minchia sono e siamo entrati
in quello che chiameremo parco bello
perché non ho idea di dove siamo
guardiamocelo un po' la vedo delle
costruzioni incredibili sembrano quelle
di buon residenti vol 4 Oh bellissimo
sempre sognato di venire qui Questa è la
Salve signore
è un posto con un tavolo e
basta
ma insomma degli schermi grossi più
grossi perché uno schermo ogni 3 secondi
Anche laggiù Infatti lui è tutto
scazzato bella sta via Oh Questo è corso
Buenos Aires Potevate dirmelo prima che
questa era un paradiso terrestre
Comunque è strano raga perché Dovunque
vado C'è roba incredibilmente fatta bene
poi non scontata Cioè ma cos'è sta
Fontana incredibile Cioè è pazzesco Ah
la vedo una roba che mi interessa
[Risate]
casa tua vedo che c'è anche un po'
d'amore per la Italo patria che comunque
sia non manca né in Giappone né in Corea
ho paura anche solo ad annusare il
profumo di questa cucina ma a prezzo che
ci provino a prezzo a prezzo potete
farlo anche un parco brutto eh Se vi
capita però vabbè Oddio è blockbusters
una cosa che ho notato della Corea è che
ce l'hanno con le olive Non so perché
olive Optical
[Musica]
ostello olive il museo umile anche là ci
sta uno schermo oggi e boh cioè mi
sembra assurdo Dopodiché arriviamo a una
delle mainaction della Corea di Seul in
particolare che questo si chiama
Givenchy ed è praticamente un tempio
storicamente noto per cose che non
conosco però vabbè ci sta Burnout qua
che però non so cosa significhi perché
c'è una scritta qua che chiaramente non
è usufruibile da un occidentale come me
quindi adesso utilizzerò Google
Translate per capire cosa c'è scritto
qua stanno preparando gli addobbi di
natale ci sta perché siamo a giugno
Comunque non so cosa sia sta roba eh
Ragazzi buongiorno Credo che stiamo
facendo delle installazioni in questo
momento perché vedo che si smontano
montano non si capisce nulla qualsiasi
cosa sia è bello se lo smontate portate
a portarmelo a casa mia a Milano
L'indirizzo è via Ragazzi vi prego vi
prego vi prego ma è tipo in 3D adesso
spunta il coniglio Guardate È pazzesco
dal video secondo me non rende perché si
vede che flickera è normale quando
riprendi col telefono lo schermo penso
sia lo schermo più grosso che abbia mai
visto a prescindere in più in 3D cioè
pazzesca sta roba raga e arriviamo
finalmente alla Pagoda che precede il
tempio di Jon Gong è una parola
bellissima è una pagoda e questo è il
tempio è la mia meta principale da
quando sono uscito dall'albergo Ed
eccoci all'entrata noto subito che c'è
un sacco ma un sacco di gente ma la cosa
più suggestiva è questa ragazzi
È pazzesco e io sono vestito qua da
squid game sono ridicolo Porca
Ho preso l'unica pozzanghera che c'era
prima cosa da fare mi sa che sono i
biglietti che si fanno là onesto umile
devo fare la coda dietro a Zorro la
prima cosa che Notiamo all'interno e la
sua età sembra l'interno del Castello
Sforzesco a Milano versione orientale
sono molto d'accordo con questa mia
teoria Quindi speriamo che Alberto
Angela non guardi questo video e vabbè
entriamo sulla Amazon quanto figo
bellissimo Forza Napoli Ciao roba che
volevo dire appena arrivati in Corea e
ho aspettato questo momento è tanto
tempo ehm com'era Ah sì Corea 2 Italia 1
arbitro pupazzo le cose importanti Tra
l'altro qua vicino credo che c'è un
villaggio molto caratteristico ma prima
Andrea a visitare la parte della natura
è un po' Nara questo qualcuno che stanno
nei Cervi selvatici in Corea qua non
vedo Cervi In compenso non so niente di
questo posto però è figo e quindi
ragazzi è un'ora che cammino in sto
parco titanico nonostante questo più
andare avanti e più ci sono cose
incredibili Cioè veramente ve lo giuro
ve lo giuro eh se ho fatto tutte i cosi
che avete visto prima non so come
tornare indietro Sostanzialmente però
Madonna Santa Benedetta Ma che posto è
pazzesco contentissimo scelta numero uno
quella di venire in Corea Ok ragazzi
dopo tutto il parco ridiamo faccio sesso
a questo luogo Ok questo ombrello E ci
si deve togliere le scarpe ok te lo dico
dammi Quali sono le mie perché sennò mi
rubo i sandali e vediamo cosa c'è qua
dentro Non so cosa ci sia
Che cazzo fai tipo una libreria Che
figata non so leggere ma qui in italiano
Fabio Volo Eccolo qua
Oddio povero
Tutto chiaro e qua ci si siede si legge
molto molto non ho capito perché ci
si deve togliere le scarpe Però vabbè
qua mi fa molto piacere che hanno messo
in vetrina la lista della spesa che mi
dava mia madre quando mi diceva di
andare al supermercato molto figo Tutto
molto bello sto posto molto molto bello
e poi c'è l'entrata per un paio nel
paese delle meraviglie Alice Ancora non
l'ho vista Vabbè ragazzi con questo
teoricamente abbiamo finito il parco c'è
una roba lì proprio non so esattamente
Ragazzi dove son finito incantata questa
effettivamente se ci pensate non so se
questo è un videogioco o se siamo nella
realtà questa cosa ve la saprò dire tra
un po' Eh sarà il jet lag non lo so cioè
perché Perché Ah l'ho già vista questa
cosa Eh l'ho già vista questa cosa qua
sono acculturato ragazzi Questo si
chiama cultura e comunque è vero raga
che sono fissati con la pepsia Cioè non
erano da abbattuta alla fine sono
veramente fissati poi inizierà a piovere
ma son contento che sono riuscito a fare
sta riprese adesso Tra l'altro non si
percepisce la video c'è un umidità
incredibile Sto morendo Infatti adesso
vado a farmi la doccia un'altra cosa
strana della Corea sono i Won soldi
coreani visto diecimila von 10.000 Won
sono tipo 7 euro più o meno perché un
euro equivale a 1.400 sono strani Mi
ricordano un po' le banconote canadesi
anche un po' i franchi svizzeri
effettivamente è figo perché non sembra
il coso del Monopoli infatti nel
Monopoli coreano ci hanno gli euro
sicuramente bene Comunque qua c'è
un'altra cosa tutto io mentre dico stai
cazzate sto passando in posti pseudo
incredibili Ma non vi so spiegare niente
di quello che sto vedendo però
complimenti per l'estate bravo anche a
pezzi bravissimo Questo è uno di piatti
tipici della Corea gli ho detto che lo
poteva scolare e lui mi ha tolto proprio
il fornello e me l'ha messo qua perché
sta ancora bollendo io se non voglio
morire Mi sa che devo aspettare un
attimo Vorrei saper di dire di più il su
Che cos'è Diciamo che noodles vegetali
consigliato di mangiare una volta qui a
seduta la casa Magica di tutto ciò è che
all'interno troviamo anche una salvietta
che comunemente commestibile in piazza
si sta parlando tutto Scusatemi ragazzi
Allora ragazzi sono uscito e sono anche
ben attrezzato per la pioggia a primo
impatto Mi dà ovviamente tante già
panvibes le cose sembrano messe un po'
più a cazzo rispetto al Giappone però
comunque tutto pulito Ecco forse meno un
pelo meno ordinato Comunque anche a
vendere roba strana anche qua Te la
cavano soprattutto perché un Pikachu
così grosso ragazzi non l'ho visto
neanche al Pokémon Center quello a
shibuya quindi non so E anche i Digimon
magico Oh raga ma tutto bene questo
finisce una valigia quello no la magia
di questo posto si chiama miong dong che
ci sono un miliardo di bancarelle che
fanno vendono cibo dove vende roba Rossa
Vabbè ragazzi che dire Mi dispiace che
sta piovendo in tutto questo casino Però
comunque si lo stesso della bellezza di
questo posto Non voglio tutto c'è una
bancarella degli Oreo Boh tutto molto
strano molto bello però ah ah umile
umile tutto molto umile mi dicono e
quindi ragazzi arriviamo al momento in
cui sto per entrare in metropolitana e
speriamo che qualcuno mi schiaffeggi No
scherzo siccome sono talmente abituato
alla swica in Giappone per la metro qua
non so niente
però comunque questa non è una metro
ragazzi non so ragazzi Io volevo una
Vorrei andare in giro Black vinco
Comunque blackpink raga' tutto ci sono i
cosi cioè le bancarelle del k-pop magico
magico mi ricordo che una volta tipo in
Sicilia vendevano una piastrelle con la
mia faccia Penso sia più o meno la cosa
analoga che però c'ha Seul Ragazzi ho
trovato anche già che ci siamo Ehm cosa
commento a fare non commentiamo più Oh
siamo dentro al centro commerciale
ragazzi perché dalla metro che non ho
visto comunque sia entra nel centro
commerciale stanno tutti a mangiare sono
le sei di pomeriggio che cazzo mangiano
e vedi pomeriggio ah figo c'è
l'hamburgheria melting Soul anime
fondute
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ragazzi Questo è il k-pop dello sfizio
bellissimo
tutte faccine torta al contrario è
storta dall'altra parte Ah voi ci sta la
banga
Ci stanno pure lampadario
adesso andiamo a vedere arredamento che
poi se c'è qualcosa bello in barca e lo
porta Milano
non rimaniamo qua che se non mi
copyright nel video Grazie raga in
coreano ho deciso di fare Accessorize
gli hanno uniti tutti insieme hanno
fatto un gigantesco accessories primo
posto dove si cena ragazzi il barbecue
buffe coreano Voglio una roba veloce
Oggi voglio stare tranquillo e domani in
una giornata lunga Non capisco perché
comunque entro lo sentirei pop per forza
mettono il k-pop a qualsiasi sito anche
nel cesso Infatti il suo video sarà
copiato 60 volte è un all you can eat di
carne ragazzi Iper strano freddo vieni
qua da questo vapore magico prendi una
ciotola e ti metti le cose che vuoi Non
mi ispira una sega di quello che sto
vedendo però quello sì ma ehm non va qua
dentro sicuramente Vai nell'altro piatto
adesso lo prendo qua metterò qualcosa
che ormai l'ho ottenuto e quindi fa
brutto solo riposo prendo questo che non
so cosa sia se ti viene una pancia tanto
attenzione che poi esplodere ma ci sta
ci sta come avvertimento ci sta Allora
io non so che cosa sto facendo
però
posso anche copiare dagli altri perché
non sono sta facendo un cazzo mettiamo
un pezzo di carne all you can eat che ho
appena preso mettiamo qua
per altre ricette Seguitemi
ragazzi sono davvero dei capelli lo
vedete dallo sguardo sono smentito sto
facendo 6 milioni di Cori in Corea
dovunque vai Ci sono 65.000 cose da fare
però vabbè Questo video giunge al
termine ma stanno per uscire altri video
perché cioè veramente qua è una roba
allucinante Quindi venerdì prossimo
uscirà un altro video sempre qua appunto
in Corea eccetera Poi tornerò anche a
Tokyo quindi non perdetevi i prossimi
video perché vi assicuro meritano andrò
anche a visitare la zona di Gangnam
Gangnam Style non sapete presente Una
magica canzone quindi ci vediamo al
prossimo video ragazzi e spero vi sia
piaciuto iscrivetevi al canale
della descrizione e noi ci vediamo al
prossimo video prossimo viaggio a un
prossimo video a Seul Mamma mia guarda
che cacchio di capelli ma chi se ne
frega dai ragazzi